get over me of course I know and I know
one another winning night maybe she's
been baby the proof mm yeah damn damn
one live from the studio dropping two
songs tomorrow I've been waiting to drop
them anyway but yeah oh oh my goodness
the best in the world you see it
damn hey you why you heated will react
tonight look at the city I left the city
you got to see the city tonight oh my
goodness hold on I walk this way you got
to see the city my voice is going yeah I
see a city
oh [ __ ] it is going crazy
I'll go for the gods yeah mmhmm yeah
uh-huh hey clay I remember that thing
you said about me that one time at that
one game I'm a letter fly bill I told
Stefan I'm a lettuce slide you didn't
mean it
huh you didn't mean it
it's all good when I see you I'm
wakeboarding with your friends this
summer we're in Quicksilver shorts it's
gonna be all love I know you didn't mean
it
huh you didn't mean it
Big Dawg what up hi REE I think he's
only people that follow that can comment
on here so song yeah it's all good
a chip to the six sour cream and onion
and I'm saying creamy garlic jalapeno
cheddar hi I want to dip because we got
the chip so how y'all wanted
how y'all wanted how you want to dip oh
my goodness
two songs dropping tomorrow and I'm
designing the rings what else what else
do you want from me
huh what else do you want for me they
said I was occurs now they're cursing
each other out and they're out of town
because uh they asked me kindly not to
attend for safety reasons and I obliged
because you know I have respect for the
league so you know but I'm here I'm in
the city and that's what matters we won
then pinging my money been stopped it
eight stopping and things are tight all
my life and pay me my money go go
scrounge together I changed from you my
man yeah
so all jokes is how you got very lucky
yeah it's all good man listen you could
debate and analyze you could go on
espn.com backslash message boards
backslash we don't give a [ __ ] and you
could you could comment on there go
write all that go write all that run it
there but look much love there's two
songs dropping tomorrow a championship
to the City of Toronto for the first
time ever Congrats well-deserved for the
people and uh oh yeah gwap co-op dad
owes me the craziest bet in the world
but out but I'll bring that to you later
that's I'll reveal that slowly but
surely Scotia Bank Arena in the
background thank you to everybody you
see that hat the best in the world
we did it hahahaha hehehehe guys stupid
are you crazy are you done which one you
could pick one you know what time it is
man yo clay when you're wakeboarding in
this summer when you're wakeboarding and
you're quick selfish shorts you know
what time it is when you see me you
better wave friendly to ie ie are you as
dumb